- We should also mention that
cause this is amazing
this is your directorial
debut in the movie, right?
- [Lin] Yes.
- This is the, this is really
cool tick, tick...BOOM.
- Yeah, tick, tick...BOOM.
- tick, tick...BOOM
(applause)
- So what, what is the,
what's the behind the story?
I read about it.
I think it's fascinating.
I actually didn't know this.
But tell everybody what it's about.
- Yeah, I'm here talking
to you today because
I saw Rent for my 17th birthday.
That was the show
that made me feel like
I could write musicals.
It felt so personal
and homemade and
- [Kelly] It's very raw.
- I then found out that Jonathan Larson
wrote the musical before that
and he wrote a musical
about being a songwriter
and no one producing his work.
And just like,
I feel like it's never
gonna happen for me.
And it's, it's really a,
he wrote this one man show
that was autobiographical about turning 30
and spending his twenties,
writing a musical
that no one wanted to produce.
And it felt
I saw it just when I
was graduating college
and it just felt like a
message in a bottle to me.
And so, you know, because he's the person
who really got me
started writing musicals.
I wanted to make a movie of that show.
- Yeah.
- And the amazing Andrew Garfield
is embodying Jonathan Larson in the movie
- [Kelly Wow
- and he's singing and playing
piano and he's incredible.
And it was just like an amazing
- Such a huge thing in
pop culture that Rent.
I mean, it was just
- [Lin] absolutely.
- Yeah it hit, I will never not hear
♪ 525,600. ♪
I mean literally if anybody says 500
that's where my brain goes.